[Music]
the stork is on the way we'll see how it
trickles down from 60 style to the front
porch nick cannon and brittany bell
announced their third child together
with this major photo shoot brittany a
former miss universe contestant rocked
nine different looks showing off her
baby bone
after britney's announcement the meme
world went wild poking fun at the father
of ten how nick cannon facetimes his
kids nick cannon taking his kids to the
pool another one and this dj khaled
catchphrase on repeat another one
another one
meanwhile new mom bri thiasi who gave
birth to legendary love cannon in june
was spotted out in west hollywood
yesterday the 31 year old is the newest
cast member of netflix's selling sunset
do you ever communicate with any of the
other ladies no i respect everyone's you
know space at some point we will we just
don't necessarily need to at the moment
31 year old abby de la rosa is also
rumored to be expecting nick's child oh
yeah it's a lot to unpack so here's a
closer look at nick's complicated family
tree the 41 year old has fathered eight
children with five different women there
are two more that we know of on the way
nick's twins with mariah carey moroccan
and monroe are 11 years old
nick recently called mimi his fantasy
love is the door still open at least
cracked
they don't want me
as for the other four ladies a source
tells e.t the mothers of nick cannon's
children are cordial and respectful to
each other for the most part we're also
told nick does his best to carve out
time for everyone but there's a twist
we talked to bree not too long ago she
said sometimes you guys go through the
assistant we all can go through the
assistant to make sure it's on the
calendar if there's something important
i was like oh yeah that's going to go
viral
and it did it looked like uh is is nick
available to see his child
can you put me in at 2 am what she was
saying is my children have busier
schedules than i do so no one has to
call my assistant to get to me
[Music]